Cette photo a été publiée partout.
Les gens l'ont postée délibérément,
pour qu'elle s'affiche en haut des résultats.
Ils se sont assurés que la légende soit « Michelle Obama »,
et que le nom du fichier téléchargé soit « MichelleObama.jpeg ».
Dans un seul but : manipuler le résultat des recherches.
Et ça a fonctionné.
Quand on cherchait une image d'elle sur Google en 2009,
cette photo de singe déformée arrivait dans les premiers résultats.
Les résultats sont en fait auto-correctifs.
C'est ça qui fait la beauté du système.
Google mesure la pertinence des données en continu.
Or, dans ce cas précis, Google est allé plus loin.
Ils ont pensé : « C'est un acte raciste, et le résultat est erroné.
Revenons en arrière, et corrigeons manuellement.
On va écrire un code et corriger ça ! »
Aussitôt dit, aussitôt fait.
Je suis absolument sûr que tout le monde ici trouve l'idée bonne.
Moi aussi.
Cependant, quelques années plus tard,
l'Anders le plus recherché sur Google,
Anders Behring Breivik,
a commis les actes que l'on sait.
Le 22 Juillet 2011 restera un jour noir dans l'histoire de la Norvège.
Cet homme, un terroriste, a fait sauter quelques bâtiments administratifs,
à un jet de pierre d'Oslo, où nous sommes.
Il s'est ensuite rendu dans l'ile d'Utøya
et a tiré sur un groupe d'enfants.
Presque 80 personnes sont mortes ce jour-là.
La plupart des gens pensent que cet acte horrible a deux étapes.
Un, il fait sauter les immeubles ; et deux, il tue ces enfants.
Ce n'est pas exact.
Il y a 3 étapes à son plan.
Il fait sauter les immeubles, il tue les enfants,
et trois, il attend que le monde entier le google.
Et il a préparé les 3 étapes minutieusement.
Quelqu'un a compris ça immédiatement :
un développeur web Suédois, Nikke Lindqvist,
spécialisé dans l’optimisation des moteurs de recherche.
Il s’intéresse aussi à la politique.
Il s'est immédiatement connecté aux réseaux sociaux, son blog, FB.
Voici ce qu'il a dit :
« Cet homme veut avant tout contrôler son image.
C'est son objectif principal.
Tentons de déformer ça.
Voyons si on peut, dans la monde civilisé, protester les actes qu'il a commis,
en l'insultant dans les résultats de recherche. »
Comment faire ?
Il a demandé à tous ses lecteurs :
« Allez sur Internet,
trouvez des photos de crottes de chien sur les trottoirs,
des crottes de chien,
et postez-les sur vos sites web, sur vos blogs.
Mentionnez le nom du terroriste dans la légende de la photo,
et donnez au fichier le nom « Brievik.jpeg. »
Apprenons à Google que tel est le visage d'un terroriste. »
Ça a marché.
Deux ans après la campagne contre Michelle Obama,
cette campagne manipulatrice contre Anders Behring Breivik a marché.
Quand on faisait une recherche des semaines après ce 22 Juillet,
cette photo de crottes de chien apparaissait en haut des résultats.
Une petite protestation.
Curieusement, Google n'est pas intervenu cette fois-ci.
Ils n'ont pas nettoyé ces résultats manuellement.
La question à cent balles consiste à savoir
s'il y a une différence entre ces deux événements.
Y a-t-il une différence entre ce qui est arrivé à Michelle Obama
et ce qui est arrivé à Anders Breivik ?
Bien sûr que non.
C'est exactement la même chose.
Cependant, Google est intervenu dans un cas et non dans l'autre.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que Michelle Obama est une personne honorable,
et Anders Breivik est une personne ignoble.
Vous comprenez ce qui se passe ?
On a porté un jugement de valeur sur une personne.
Il n'y a qu'une puissance au monde
pourvue de l'autorité de décider qui est qui.
« On vous aime, on ne vous aime pas.
On croit en vous, on ne croit pas en vous.
Vous avez raison, vous avez tort.
Vous êtes Obama, et vous êtes Breivik. »
Voilà le pouvoir à l'état brut.
C'est pour ça que je vous demande de vous rappeler
que derrière chaque algorithme, il y a toujours une personne,
avec des croyances personnelles,
qu'aucun code ne pourra jamais complètement effacer.
J'adresse mon message à Google,
et à tous les croyants en la programmation.
Vous devez identifier vos propres préjugés.
Vous devez comprendre que vous êtes humain,
et prendre vos responsabilités en conséquence.
Je crois que nous avons atteint un moment où il est impératif
que nous resserrions les liens entre l'humanisme et la technologie,
et que nous les cultivions comme jamais auparavant.
Si vous ne deviez retenir qu'une seule idée :
l'idée séductrice du résultat de recherche neutre, et objectif,
est et restera, un mythe.
Merci pour votre temps.
(Applaudissements)